what do you think because it's the
recent controversy of Andrew Tate
and that he I think in the past ran a
caming business and he's being accused
of sex trafficking what do you think
like from your own experience
what do you understand about Andrew Tate
is he a good person is he a bad person
is there something Shady about his
practices or not I wish I could answer
but I don't know I haven't looked into
it at all I've heard people talking
about I just haven't bothered to go into
it it is well known that like when I was
doing it back in the day the Eastern
European models had something different
going on though it was like a Trope
about you know there's the Eastern
European models and then there's
everybody else they're there what it's
like darker or something like they do
Studios and they're lower quality
which means what the studios are you go
into like a warehouse and then they have
set up a little like things that
replicate bedrooms yeah but they're just
like stalls
and then you give you rent out or you
pay the studio percentage of your income
and you can tell when something looks
like a studio it's like a type of
background yeah that if you're like
watching enough it kind of starts to you
notice the patterns so like the
standards are lower there in the ethical
boundaries are a little looser yeah
people are treated it's Uncle we didn't
I never heard anything about the ethical
site I just knew that it was like lower
quality like the girls seemed like they
were less into it and like
Carriage less how does this all
interplay with like sex trafficking so
consensual versus non-consensual I would
be sure never any non-consensual camping
um I mean I guess it's like if it were
going to happen not going to be
surprised if it were in fact Eastern
European models based on this is
outdated this is I'm just thinking of my
stereotypes back when I came a lot sure
so some of that is stereotyped versus
like collecting good data right yeah I
haven't done data on cam girl it's hard
I mean it's hard it's even hard to get
that data right
um yeah but obviously a really important
problem there's a method that I'm trying
that I really like I designed a survey
type which is like asking people who you
know yeah like who do you who do you
know who's done this and you tell me
like oh do you know anybody who's a
doctor do you know anybody who you know
has had cancer or like smokes or
personally I mean yeah personally just
do you know anybody yeah um and then if
you ask about a whole bunch of things
you can calibrate the responses so like
that's really interesting if you're if
your population you know 20 of them know
doctors and then you know the actual
amount of doctors then you can tell like
how this is corresponding like what is
the visibility of doctors so you can
reconstruct the graph basically yeah and
and we can do this with sex trafficking
and of course people are going to be
like well sex trafficking is not visible
people you don't know those like well
then we can ask about other non-visible
things that other people don't know that
we do have data for like homelessness or
being in jail or like uh if you have
been like sexually assaulted a lot of
people don't like talking about if
they've been sexually assaulted so you
can do a whole bunch of things that are
like similarly suppressed in knowledge
in some way that we do actually have
rates for and then compare that to the
graph when we ask people do you know
anybody who's in sex trafficked yeah so
again this is not perfect I'm not saying
this is you can refer things you can
infer things about that graph but let's
say we don't have good ways of measuring
sex trafficking right now anyway I did a
big deep dive into the research that we
have and sex trafficking in the western
world and the actual like I read the
studies and like reports about the
studies and it's really pitiful we have
terrible data it's like there's just
like vague estimations made from one guy
in a basement in the 80s that's like the
basis for like one big study that like a
lot of people report on it was and so
I'm like okay so the the method I'm
proposing obviously is not perfect but
like the bar is so low at this point
well I wonder also if there's a ways to
design a survey that gets at the um at
the victims of sex trafficking also
which is they presumably have public
access to the internet
and I wonder how many of them are
distinctly aware that they're victims
like it's asking the question
it when you're inside of a toxic
relationship are you inside of a toxic
relationship I mean if if the toxic
relationship is truly toxic sometimes
your your mind is [__] with right
you're not you don't even know what's
true yeah so it's interesting if you can
design surveys actively sex right yeah
who could break through that so
basically get data on how many people
are getting sex trafficked directly oh
yeah like if you don't frame it like if
you don't say the word sex trafficking
you're like are you just in a situation
where you'd and maybe through the survey
I mean that's very meta but through the
survey help them you know I did this
this is what started my relationship
surveys so I've done a series of
relationship surveys and that was
because I knew somebody in a terrible
relationship and I was like I bet if she
took a survey where she answered
questions about her relationship and at
the end got a score that compared her to
everybody else she'd be like oh wait
everybody else has much better
relationships than I do so that's why I
started making the relationship surveys
was exactly for that reason yeah that's
really really powerful to know that like
you're not
you're not crazy for thinking this is a
bad relationship right or I think like
the actual question is like could you do
better if you broke up I think that the
thing that keeps most people in their
relationships is like this is the best
that I can do like this is normal and if
if it were normal I would say that they
are right like if you live in a culture
where everybody is abusing their their
people in their relationships then yeah
you I mean what are you gonna do break
up and then just be alone for the rest
of your life most people don't want to
do that but not comparing yourself to
the to the average is good to know to
know no your options are at least
understand it because you know being
normal is not always like this
conversation is not always great
um
meaning this this conversation is
anything but normal